The Joe Rogan Experience so we decided
to have this conversation because of
what's going on with you in Canada oh
yeah and that your Clinical Psychology
license is in Jeopardy because you have
opinions
about politics that they disagree with
which is a very dangerous and bizarre
turn of events well it's your fault
actually you know I told you I think a
week or so ago when we talked about this
this okay so let me give you some
background here so I want to know how
it's my fault I will I'll tell you and
tell you a lot of things are your fault
as it turns out oh no yeah yeah so the
the College of psychologists has
basically levied what are equivalent to
about 13 lawsuits against me
simultaneously now the reason I call
them lawsuits is because their actions
undertaken on behalf of a complainant
now the complainant can be anyone
anywhere in the world who complains
about me for any reason they don't have
to be former clients they don't even
have to be anybody I've ever met they
don't even have to have met anybody I've
ever met so you know so it could be
someone online well it is all this is
pretty much all these complaints are
someone online none of them are my
clients although half of them claim to
be falsely and the college didn't throw
out their complaints despite that so
which is really quite interesting and
what are the complaints well okay let's
see uh the one complaint is about the
tweet I made about Eleanor Elliot page
and when I said that a criminal
physician cut off her breasts and the
pride was the sin so now I'm in trouble
again because I just said the same thing
one was about Sports Illustrated cover
where they featured that overweight
model and I tweeted out not beautiful
and I guess that was something like fat
shaming I don't remember exactly what
the what the what the charge was and
then I criticized Justin Trudeau and a
former staff member of Justin Trudeau
and Jacinda ardern I made a joke about
her coming I was going to New Zealand
and the New Zealand leftist pressed was
freaking out and I made this joke about
bringing my alt-right trolls to New
Zealand and then I put in parentheses or
maybe they're just you know ordinary
people who are trying to clean up their
rooms so apparently that was
casting the profession into disgrace and
then they submitted one complainant from
the U.S
submitted the entire transcript of our
last discussion so you know I don't know
how to defend myself against that
because apparently everything I say and
apparently everything you say too is
bringing the profession of psychology
into disgrace and I think they're most
upset in that case about my comments
about the inadequacy of climate models
and so you know part of the reason I'm
pursuing this action
with regard to the Ontario College of
psychologists while there's two reasons
really one three one is you know leave
me the hell alone guys you've been on my
case non-stop for seven years
not once before that in 20 years of
practice there's no complaints ever
levied against me
it wasn't until I started to become you
know relatively well known publicly that
the college came after me and seven
years of that gets to be a bit much
especially now that there's 13 lawsuits
compiled up and all of them are for
political opinions and half of them have
been put forward on false grounds but
but even that's not enough for me to
engage in the battle
the reason I'm engaging in the battle is
well first of all you want me to do
social media retraining so I communicate
better according to your experts it's
like experts by what criteria exactly
what's a social Media communication
expert you got a documentation that that
even exists as a field how do you know
that if you have that social media
expert train me that I'm going to be a
better therapist there's no body of data
that suggests that in the least so I'm
not going down that route we should
explain that because
this isn't a threat by the college
this is what what the situation already
is I haven't been hauled in front of
their disciplinary board yet but they've
already convicted me of disgracing the
profession and sentenced me to an
indefinite period of re-education
and that's the second most serious
punishment that they can Levy against a
professional the first is to take away
the license the second is to undergo
this retraining and to publicly announce
the necessity for that which they've
already done in my case and so now I
have to sit down with these experts at
my expense for an indefinite period of
time until I'm trained properly whatever
the hell that means by the criteria of
the so-called experts and the college
and that isn't pending an investigation
that's already in place such a wild
request to retraining just even the way
they phrase it it's so bizarre so
orwellian yeah yeah well like I said
it's your social media the whole
transcript of our last conversation I
don't imagine they'll be that happy with
this one so but the other reason I'm
pursuing it and to the degree that I'm
able to keep my head cleared during this
process because it definitely makes me
angry and really made me angry over
Christmas when I was spending Christmas
going through the minutia of all these
bloody lawsuits trying to figure out
what the hell they were up to instead of
you know taking a bit of a break and
having some time with my family and so I
was very upset about that but to the
degree that I'm upset about it I'm not
doing it right eh because this can't be
personal can't be about me
part of the reason that I want to pursue
this and part of the reason we're
pursuing an objection to what they're
doing on Charter of Rights grounds in
Canada is because they're interfering
with my freedom of conscience and speech
and again it isn't even the case that
the reason that that's a problem is
because it's about me the reason it's a
problem is because the colleges in
general like the regulatory Boards of
professionals are doing this to everyone
lawyers Physicians teachers massage
therapists there's all these licensed
professions and if you're if you're a
licensed profession the government
establishes a board of your peers to
regulate conduct of the professionals
now and in a functional time all that
happens then is that generally the
people who get in trouble get in trouble
with their own clients right with the
people they've been dealing with
directly and then the board steps in on
the side of the person who's been
injured by a you know a pathologically
practicing professional and fair enough
but now it's been weaponized and it's
not it's been weaponized as a political
tool too and it's not like activists
don't know that you know and it's so
Preposterous because I have 20 million
people following me on social media you
know and God only knows how many views
of my videos for example or the
interviews you and I have done it's tens
of millions and like they
what how many people complained
out of millions and then the college
didn't have to pursue those complaints
they can invent they have to investigate
them
so I don't know what they're doing now
because of course they've been inundated
by thousands of complaints about their
own behavior so I have no idea what
they're going to do about that but they
didn't have to investigate they chose to
investigate and as I said they did that
despite the fact that half the
complainants
claimed to be my clients
and weren't so what we have here is we
have 13 people
who complained about me hypothetically
doing harm
to someone they didn't know
to someone who they didn't know anyone
who knew
on as a consequence of things I said on
social media and that all of them not
only were they fourth hand claims of
harm
which you know no psychologist would
ever claim that a fourth hand account of
harm constituted a valid measurement so
the bloody college is violating its own
measurement standards by even pursuing
this but so not only are they based on
Fourth hand information and then an
outright lie which is they were clients
of mine
there they're they're also predicated on
the assumption that
it's okay to go after a professional for
expressing political criticism
because like literally half of them are
well I said something about Trudeau
I said something about one of his top
aides I said something wrote Jacinda
ardern I said something about
an Ottawa city councilor in relationship
to the trucker Convoy
you know I said something about climate
every single one of the complaints is
political and so why is that a problem
well see if you can figure it out for
yourself that'd be the first answer and
the second is
I have a friend in Canada very
well-known physician International
reputation and a reasonably decent
secondary income stream and when this
all hit I reached out to him he's a very
brave guy he's done a lot of writing
that could easily get him in trouble
I said look maybe I could get you and
Bruce party this lawyer at Queen's
University who's going after the
essentially the college that functions
for lawyers I said we should do three
letters same time saying they know that
the colleges are chilling free speech in
Canada with psychologists with with
Physicians and with lawyers and he said
he didn't have his house in order enough
to dare to take on the college and the
problem with that is that I don't know
anybody in Canada who's a physician
that's more well situated than him or
braver and even he was loath to do it
he'll do it eventually but not now